I'm very excited that you're here I'm
excited to be here I've never been on
the show oh I know we we know and we're
very excited and we've been talking
about it all day so anyway hello and
welcome to the show how is 2024 treating
you good uh better than 2023 there you
go there so far so good yeah I love that
so I hear this I want to talk about
first yes cuz I just got into fantasy
football this season oh okay you're into
it right yeah I am do you have a group
text with the people that you're in the
league with yes I do is it not so much
fun you're not one of them are you no no
I'm saying I love it that's so fun yes
and the memes and all that sort of stuff
it's a lot of fun all of ours are over
60 ladies you find out oh I love that so
you you find I mean I've always just
watched the Cowboys growing up but like
you I find myself now loving other teams
just because of players because that
they've been on my team yeah because now
you learn about them so for example I
had Ferguson who was the the tight end
in Dallas people that showed up at our
playoff game yes yes and I'm a Green Bay
fan so sorry about that suck it okay um
I'm just kidding you know what I watch
that game and I go you know what you
deserve it oh look at your cheese said
you get into
it oh yeah with a Super Bowl ring oh my
God my my friend has that's look look
Alex is emptying the dishwasher and
that's as one does and I got my face
painted at a children's birthday party
yes for the for the G big game but my
friend does have a genuine real Super
Bowl ring so she let me wear it for that
picture why does your friend what do she
what her uh brother-in-law whatever
something there that's cool I would just
want to wear it for a minute I know huh
well any Cowboy fan would sorry anyway
sorry that was sad it might happen in
our my
[Music]
lifetime
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home